[Applause]
bts is literally stopping
it's like traffic dreams come true the
k-pop group hit the streets to perform
their biggest songs during their
crosswalk concert on the late late show
with james corden but before all that
happened the late night host prepared
the band for their latest gig today you
are going to play
the biggest venue
of your life
we just play for 50 000 people at sophie
city
now he wants us to play next to some gas
station
and even though bts is known for their
flawless choreography james had some
suggestions of his own most of stuff
like
[Music]
the group then performed their hit song
butter alongside some familiar breakfast
foods
[Applause]
then a quick costume change yep that's
bts in all denim hitting the crosswalk
to sing permission to dance
[Music]
the band then finished things up with a
colorful performance of dynamite which
literally had fans dancing out of their
cars
[Music]
can't help but smile seeing bts all
together because earlier this month they
announced they're taking a hiatus but
don't worry they made it very clear
they're not breaking up just taking some
time to rest and it's well deserved
because the superstars had a jam-packed
year they released butter played
multiple sold out shows and even racked
up a few trophies at the american music
awards when it caught up with the guys
ahead of the awards show they couldn't
help but share their excitement for
performing for their fans the army again
in person we waited this for
so so long time so it's like a dream
yeah it's like a dream i mean we
actually dreamed of this dream so it's
crazy um i mean like we're just here to
have a good time with the armies with
the actual people and while bts is on
their hiatus we'll just be over here
continuing to play their crosswalk
performance on repeat
[Music]
like